to hong kong now for more than two
decades a sculpture has stood at a
university commemorating the victims of
the tiananmen square massacre this piece
of artwork is now facing removal and
it's being seen by activists as the
latest sign of beijing's suppression of
freedom in the territory the pillar of
shame depicts 50 torn and twisted bodies
that symbolize victims of the government
crackdown on june 4th 1989. on the
anniversary every year students clean
and scrub the artwork it stood on campus
since 1997. the pillar is part of a
series of sculptures by danish artist
jens garcia he loaned this one to a
pro-democracy group but it was disbanded
last month and some of its members are
accused of national security offenses
amid the crackdown the university sent a
lawyer's letter to the group demanding
the removal of the artwork the pillar is
the last remaining tiananmen
commemoration on chinese soil
and we have the artist jens garcia with
us now jens thank you for joining us
you were informed by the media about the
demand that your sculpture be removed
and then you received that lawyer's
letter that we mentioned and you're
accusing the university of acting like
the mafia why
just because of the university of hong
kong they sent a letter to the people
from the democracy movement and say this
they should move this sculpture in four
days and
these people are going are sitting in
jail of course they can move a sculpture
uh and uh
that must have a lawyer in hong kong and
now we have saying this is my sculpture
is not allowed to move that you must
have the discussion with me and not with
the democratic democracy movement so
this is the kind of mathematics of doing
that because they say if you don't move
the sculpture in fourth day then we will
destroy it
well i want to ask you about that letter
that you got it was sent by the u.s firm
that's working on behalf of the
university this firm is named meyer
brown so they issued the demands that
the statute be taken down and they've
come under heavy criticism we reached
out to them and they sent us the
following statement that i want to read
out to you they said quote we were asked
to provide a specific service on a real
estate matter for our long-term client
the university of hong kong our role as
outside council is to help our clients
understand and comply with the current
law our legal advice is not intended as
a commentary on current or historical
events jens what do you make of that
i think this is crap it's really crap
this is a firm now on their website say
they are protect human rights and then
they're saying this is okay if it's the
connection to the law into the new bad
law in hong kong where there is a
security law who would they have used to
put all the democracy movement in jail
and say okay we just help the university
to
have
to do to move the sculpture inside the
law
this is this is really not
this is really crap
well i should say what the university
has said to all of this they told the
news agency reuters that they're getting
legal advice that they're working with
the related parties to handle this in a
reasonable way and you mentioned that
you've hired a lawyer yourself and
you've offered to move the statue is
that going to be possible and where
would it go
yes i i i have said to them it's okay i
will move this to the stage if you don't
want to have it there i will move it and
i don't know where i should move it of
course i will try to move some other
place in hong kong but i'm not sure this
is allowed to do that because maybe this
security law says this is not allowed to
have a monument about the genuine
crackdown at all if not then i will take
uh take it down and bring it somewhere
else maybe the united states washington
dc they have offered me a place and
there's another place maybe i could i
could really like to put it in taiwan
but i'm not sure the government in
taiwan will like that so in a way uh i'm
confused where i put it but we will save
it for the for destruction in hong kong
in a way but we need some time to to
bring it out to make it transport this
kind of thing
i have to ask you know pro-democracy
groups like the one that you loaned this
statue to
they are disappearing fast in hong kong
i mean how do you feel about the
developments we're seeing there
it's really really sad as i work with
these people in 25 years
where we put the monument together with
them and it's really sad some of them
the old one i know they have really one
of the most respected people uh and
peace people in in in hong kong and it
may be in health asia they are quite
famous and then they put them in jail
it's completely this is really sad and
also all the young students i think this
is a really sad story and the people are
looking the whole world i'm looking on
hong kong now by the smash
all freedom of expression and the
semester democracy movement and this is
complete against what china will promise
britain when they take over in hong kong
they promised britain to have one
country two system and now they smash
all this
rule uh
it should be in 50 years
but okay but they break the
agreement so this is china that is
behind all this this thing that happened
in hong kong now
we'll have to leave it there artist jens
garcia joining us thank you
thank you very much